I get a lot of messages how do I find my
Layla or more specifically how do I make
my wife into Layla which is a weird
message to get be like a woman saying
like how can I make my man taller it's
just not going to happen Layla has never
tried to change me and I've never really
tried to change her so I think that
making sure that you're picking somebody
who has the same long-term goal as you
has the same values as you the single
greatest one is you want to grow they
want to grow growth is also another word
for change which means that if you have
two people who are changing you just
better hope they'd be changing the same
direction